okay so now I want you to come down to
the second half of the page and this
function should look familiar
have a look at the numbers there do you
remember this for this money really
that's like four times right this is x
squared plus 5x plus 6 I'm only telling
you that so you actually know what some
of these values are for example that
vertex you know exactly where it is
right what's the Y value it's negative
1/4 right leaves is 0.25 right so can
you tell me what is the reciprocal of
negative 1/4 it's negative 4 isn't it so
keep you here how I keep on saying what
is the Y value or what is the Y value so
when I'm taking the reciprocal what I'm
turning upside down is the Y value if
that's negative 1/4 negative 4 looks
like it's gonna be about here right so
let's go ahead let's put a cross there
negative 4 is there think about how we
did the hyperbola up the top here right
what other important values did I search
for y equals can anyone suggest to me
what might be an important value that I
looked for I got there are there are
wildly sense right and I was like oh
that's six I know what the reciprocal of
six is it's 1 over 6 that's a bit harder
to put on but you can still it's gonna
be pretty close to 0 isn't it right so
I'm just gonna put that there
roughly let me give you a reminder right
there were some points that I looked at
some values that in the original graph
the very first one I got a vertical
asymptote what value of y in the
original function gave me an asymptote a
vertical one in the reciprocal function
where is it it's x equals two but what's
the Y value is the Y value on
concentrating on it's a zero right do
you see any places where this guy is
equal to zero I see two of them right
negative 2 and negative 3 so what shape
you're gonna draw that what's the
reciprocal of zero it's it's the
reciprocal of zero it's 1 over 0 to
undefined so what shape did we get on
the original graph we got a vertical
asymptote at those spots you're not
allowed to go there
what
so I'm gonna I'm gonna draw a vertical
vertical vertical right vertical
asymptotes here vertical asymptotes here
I've got two of them right so I'm gonna
draw in one here
so whenever the original function is
zero the reciprocal function can't exist
so it yeah because you can't divide by
zero you can't take the reciprocal of
zero because this is the value where I'm
not allowed to go right just like up
here where is the x-value I'm not
allowed to go it's our x equals two
right x equals two is the thing that
breaks things down okay in this case
it's not x equals two it's x equals
negative two and what was the other one
x equals negative three those are the
x-values that break it right so that's
why the asymptote is an x equals
negative 2 or negative 3 that's the
places I'm not allowed to go okay all
right now we've just put in these two
vertical asymptotes so we should label
them this is x equals negative 2 not
allowed to go there and x equals
negative 3 not allowed to go there
either
okay that's right when y equals 0 here
in here you can't take the reciprocal it
just explodes in your face right you're
like I can't divide by zero okay so
that's why I have a vertical asymptote
all right are there any other values
think back to when we did this one right
what are the important values did I look
at yeah Russell I did the y-intercept
though I think I've already done the
y-intercept on this one have a knife 6
gave me whatever 6 okay do you remember
I looked at these guys here see this
year doing those guys what value is that
they intersect right because Y is equal
to have a look at the graph again
what's y equal to yeah it's 1 and what
about here negative 1 the reason why
those mattered to me is because the
reciprocal of 1 is 1 and the reciprocal
of negative 1 is also negative on it so
I want you to have a look at the graph I
want you to find any places where this
graph is equal to 1 or negative 1 go
ahead look you've got a scale here right
go and find their spots and mark their
zoom and give you a second to do that
did you find them this looks like one to
me in fact what you can do is you can
literally get a ruler out right we're
graphing if you don't have a rule
anybody should and you can put a
horizontal line through there we go
through one right so I'm like oh right
there and right there those are the
points where because the original graph
is one the reciprocal is also one right
so these are my two spots right here and
yeah okay now I'm almost there I've got
a lot of important values here X's I've
got some places I'm not allowed to go
the last thing I asked was when does the
original function get big if the
original function gets big then the
reciprocal gets real small right and
also a vice versa okay so where can you
tell me the original function gets big
yeah as X values increase right that
original function is going up and up and
up never comes back and you can see
that's why I'll that's why this is so
low right because as this gets higher
the reciprocal is going to get lower
right is there anywhere else this
happens where else is the original
function big not just my right-hand side
B on the left-hand side same deal all
right you've got huge values over there
same deal so you're going to get
surprise surprise and neither horizontal
asymptote and again we're going to be
approaching y equals zero you're going
to notice this happens a lot
okay now I'm gonna point something out
on this graph that I didn't point out
before because you're starting to get a
little bit of the hang of it right can
you just um look back at the first graph
here it is really what I want you to pay
attention to is the sign that's positive
or negative the sign of the original
function versus the reciprocal function
okay so for example over on this
right-hand side here do you notice the
original function is positive yeah just
on this part what can you tell me about
the sign of the reciprocal when the
original is positive the reciprocal is
also positive let me say that again okay
when the original is positive the
reciprocal is positive what about the
other side if the original is negative
the reciprocal is negative that's so
important I want to state that I'm gonna
like write that down the sign of the
reciprocal that's the thing we're
drawing right the sign of the reciprocal
whether it's positive or negative
it matches the sign of the original if
the original was positive so is the
reciprocal if the original is negative
so is the reciprocal okay now I can use
that fact to help me let me just make
that a bit bigger for you
sorry it's messy I can use this fact to
help me with this new function okay
here's one I asked you to do if you have
a pencil or a highlighter something you
can use to shade so you don't like
completely ruin the graph you're about
to do once you've written this down
let's have a look here right where is my
original negative there's only one
little section where it's negative you
see it it's between what X values
negative two negative three right so in
this section here because the original
is negative I'm going to shade
underneath the axis whoops because if
the original is negative so will the
reciprocal the reciprocal graph I'm
about to draw it's going to be down in
here okay where is the original positive
now every other spot rights are on the
right of negative two on the left of
negative three in those areas the
original is positive so the reciprocal
also positive right something
shade those areas like so I'm gonna get
a thicker highlighter there we go
in these areas I'm shading right now you
can see the original the black graph is
positive and if the original is positive
the reciprocal will also be positive
yeah so I'll do the left-hand side as
well whoops that's a bit fatter than I
thought it was we are I just want to
know where it goes this will make it
easier for me to make sure I get the
champagne okay now once you have a look
right what we have drawn here is kind of
like this is where your reciprocal
function has to go it's got to stay in
these blue shaded areas it's got to go
through all the blue X's it's got to
obey these asymptotes that I've drawn in
okay I'm gonna give you a second to
think about where would you join up the
dots can you have a go I'm not gonna do
it for you just yet where would you
maybe do this in pencil so you can rub
out if necessary where do you think this
graph is going to go I'm gonna give you
a minute to have a think about that and
then I'm gonna come around have a look